what I want to do in this video is give
a primer I'm thinking about when to use
the Z statistic versus a T statistic
when we are doing significance tests so
there's two major scenarios that we will
see in an introductory statistics class
one is when we are dealing with
proportions so I'll write that on the
left side right over here and the other
is when we are dealing with means in the
proportion case when we're doing our
significance test we will set up some
null hypothesis that usually deals with
the population proportion we might say
it is equal to some value let's just
call that P sub one and then maybe you
have an alternative hypothesis that well
know the population proportion is
greater than that or less than that or
is just not equal to that so let me just
go with that one it's not equal to P sub
one and then what we do to actually test
to actually do the significance test is
we take a sample from the population
it's going to have a sample size of n we
need to make sure that we feel good
about making the inference we've talked
about the conditions for inference in
previous videos multiple times but from
this we calculate the sample proportion
and then from this we calculate the
p-value and the way that we do the p
value remember the p value is the
probability of getting a sample
proportion at least this extreme and if
it's below some threshold we reject the
null hypothesis and it suggests the
alternative and over here the way we do
that is well we find an associated z
value for that p for that sample
proportion and the way that we calculate
it we say okay look our z is going to be
how many of the sampling distributions
standard deviations are we away from the
mean and remember the mean of the
sampling distribution is going to be the
population proportion so here we got
this sample statistic this sample
proportion the difference between that
and the assumed proportion remember when
we do these significance tests we try to
figure out the probability assuming the
null hypothesis is true and so when we
see this P sub 0 this is the assumed
proportion from the null hypothesis so
that's the difference between these two
the sample proportion and the assumed
proportion and then you'd want to divide
it by what's often known
the city the standard error of the
statistic which is just the standard
deviation of the sampling distribution
of the sample proportion and this works
out well for proportions because in
proportions I can figure out what this
is this is going to be equal to the
square root of the assumed population
proportion times 1 minus the assumed
population proportion all of that over N
and then I would use this Z statistic to
figure out the p-value and in this case
I would look at both tails of the
distribution because I care about how
far I am either above or below the
assumed population proportion
now with means there's definitely some
similarities here you will make a null
hypothesis maybe you assume the
population mean is equal to mu1 and then
there's going to be an alternative
hypothesis that maybe your population
mean is not equal to mu1 and you're
going to do something very simple you
take your population take a sample of
size n instead of calculating a sample
proportion you calculate a sample mean
unless you can calculate other things
like a sample standard deviation but now
you have an issue you say well ideally I
would use a Z statistic and you could if
you were able to say well I could take
the difference between my sample mean
and the assumed mean and the null
hypothesis so that would be this right
over here that's what that 0 means the
assumed mean from the null hypothesis
and I would then divide by the standard
error of the mean which is another way
of saying the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution of the sample mean
but this is not so easy to figure out in
order to figure out this this is going
to be the standard deviation of the
underlying population divided by the
square root of n we know what n is going
to be if we conducted a sample but we
don't know what the standard deviation
is so instead what we do is we estimate
this and so we'll take the sample mean
we subtract from that the assumed
population mean from the null hypothesis
and we divide it by an estimate of
which is going to be our sample standard
deviation divided by the square root of
n but because this is an estimate we
actually get a better result instead of
saying hey this is an estimate of our Z
statistic we will call this our T
statistic and as we'll see by it will
then look this up in a t-table and this
will give us a better sense of the
probability